we know that the divorce situation has
been a point of contention in the
conversations you've had with dates you
have been on what are the updates on it
if any well the updates are
I have a notary and the papers here with
me ready to find the divorce papers
okay
we're gonna do it right here right now
Tanya and Sinjin
sign divorce papers Sinjin you're
willing to sign the divorce papers I'm
willing okay Tanya you're willing to
sign the divorce papers yes all right
what does everybody think you think it's
a good idea of course I just can't
believe she didn't say anything to
Debbie well Debbie was going on and on
that's so funny
well because honestly honestly it's
because I've been trying to say you're
crazy
but listen question can I finish you can
answer it Debbie let me finish I had I
liked you before but a year and a half
because of what it's an ass she's taking
it too way too personal all right okay
Tanya you ready yeah okay sending you
ready I'm ready all right let's do it
all right
here's Tanya's notary
it's an epic moment wow yes this is a
first on the tell-all yeah it's the
first time for me yeah she is such a
good liar oh my God by being so mean to
me okay let's sign this oh nice we'll
talk about this later we'll talk about
it later he's calling me a nut you're a
[ __ ] because I never thought about it
that was my answer that was a real
answer Debbie I never think about it
okay so okay
okay ready okay
[Music]